let's talk about earwax and the best way
to unclog
your ears
now of course you want to use common
sense when you're cleaning your ears
if you look on the back the label of a
q-tip it says warning do not insert this
in your ear and of course they have to
tell people that because sometimes
people will take a q-tip and just jam it
into the ear and push all the wax so it
clogs the inner ear and
potentially punctures the
eardrum so of course you have to put a
warning on that but that little hole
inside your ear is only about one inch
in width okay so it's probably about i
don't know that much so you can imagine
if you're going to stick something in
there you don't want to go too far and
so if you're going to clean your ears
you know go gentle
go superficial and use a circular motion
so you're not pushing wax internally and
there's all sorts of cleaning tools you
can use
they have ear spoons and ear scrapers
and they have even electric devices that
tend to pull things out of your ear and
that's all really great but the most
important thing you have to realize is
that you never want to over clean your
ears especially on a daily basis where
you're scrubbing and cleaning your ears
and the reason for that is based on
really what earwax is and how it can
help you now earwax is not just wax
earwax is composed of keratin protein
dead skin cells
long chain fatty acids cholesterol
the ph of earwax is slightly acidic and
it most importantly contains a massive
amount of microbes the number is roughly
10 to the seventh power so that's like
10 million
microbes so those microbes are there as
an immune defense mechanism in other
words there's a purpose for earwax is to
prevent insects from going inside your
ear it's to prevent microbes from
invading the inner ear it is one primary
barrier for your immune system to
protect against pathogens these microbes
are called commensal
microbes well what does that mean well
there's different types of commensal
relationships so you have one organism
that benefits from the other without
doing harm and then you also have mutual
benefits
and in this case it's a mutual benefit
we provide a home for the microbes and
they help us protect against pathogens i
mean the same thing happens within your
nose you have friendly bacteria in your
mouth so
if you don't understand that you might
have a tendency to over sterilize or
clean too much and create problems the
same thing happens with your skin if you
over clean your skin then you develop
acne because you don't have the friendly
bacteria to protect you and then
everything becomes red and swollen now
when people take medications for ear
infections
what that does is it can increase the
risk of getting another infection why
because you wipe out all the bacteria
and then you might have an overgrowth of
fungus so this is why many times they'll
give you an anti-fungal and an
antibacterial well the problem with that
is you start developing resistance and
so now these microbes
thrive and they and they're very
difficult to kill so you have to be
careful about wiping out this immune
protection so there's a couple things i
want to mention one is that um
if you have an overproduction of
this wax which is very similar to sebum
in your skin it's actually produced by
an oil gland as an overproduction of
this earwax that's produced inside your
ear both of them occur from the same
mechanism it's an increase in androgens
and that can come from many times a
spike in insulin so your diet has a huge
influence on how much earwax you produce
and so if you uh want to know the best
diet to help you regulate your androgens
i put a link down below in the in the
description now on the other side let's
say you want to clean your ears and you
want to soften this wax
um there's a couple things you can do
you can put a drop of hydrogen peroxide
about three percent
with a drop of olive oil why would you
use olive oil because the so-called wax
which is not really wax is like a
cholesterol
fatty acid mixture so you want to add a
fat to help
break it up and dissolve it so if you
put a drop of hydrogen peroxide with
extra virgin olive oil into one ear and
you just
lay down on one side with your ear
upward
and so it can kind of seep down in there
and wait for about three to five minutes
then you'd want to sit back up wait for
a period of time so it'll probably start
draining out so you get a little cotton
ball to catch it and then you gently
scrape and clean now of course if you
have impacted wax where it's affecting
your hearing
then go to the doctor and get that
checked out or let's say for example you
have itching
or you have some type of ear infection
there are some natural things that you
might want to consider and that would be
number one my favorite remedy colloidal
silver
put a couple drops in the ear it can act
as a natural anti-microbial okay not
just against bacteria but funguses
yeast
and even
viruses grape fruit seed extract is
another really good remedy and then my
last favorite would be oregano oil and
you can use any one of these i think
using all three would be an overkill but
any one of them would work just fine you
just put a couple drops in the ear and
it's cool because it acts as an
anti-microbial without the side effects
that some of these medications would
give you and now another question i had
in the past was what about those ear
candles does that pull wax out well at
one time i believed it did okay and i
used to try them a long ago in my
twenties i would lay down have this
candle burning out of my ear and you
would be laying there with like flames
coming out of the candle as it burnt
down and then when it burned down right
through in here hopefully you didn't let
it burn into the air you would pull it
out and you'd see a bunch of earwax on
the inside of this candle well
that's actually not ear wax okay the
earwax doesn't travel against gravity up
into this little tube
it's really the wax that's within the
candle itself that's what you're seeing
so anyway i wanted to talk about the
importance of
the microbes the microbiome that's
living on the surface of your skin and
not to
automatically just sterilize it and kill
it off but to clean your ears
periodically is a good thing but not so
often now the best video that you should
watch next would be the one on uh
controlling uh sebum and that
information is in my video on acne
so check that one out i put it right
here